bonsoir karine déchets no love co merci
d'être avec nous des sanctions donc
ciblé de la part de l'europe avec un
effet relatif voire inefficaces selon
vous en effet l'union européenne vient
simplement de démontrer son efficacité
totale à l'efficacité à de cette
politique de menaces constantes
à partir du moment où la russie ne se
plaît pas puis parlant à la volonté
politique des à la défense des intérêts
globaliste par les européennes
dans ce cas là l'union européenne a
qu'une chose à faire c'est prendre des
sanctions des sanctions qu'elle a déjà
prises rappelons le poème à l'occasion
d'un aval need aussi en octobre dernier
donc maintenant elle continue puisque
toutes ces menaces ne servent à rien
c'est montre bien quand même que ce
pouvoir le baliste n'est efficace que
dans la mesure où il fait peur et où ils
respectés appartement ou un état
souverain défend sa souveraineté et sont
absolument impuissant alors les proches
de la vanille d'ailleurs se sont dits
déçus eux aussi évidemment ils sont
déçus ils sont déçus parce que c'est eux
aussi non seulement pour aussi goûté son
poids mais c'est une question de survie
financière puisque ils sont financés ils
sont à l'étranger tant qu'ils peuvent
produire du désordre en russie la
vanille en prison la russie ayant tenu
quelques sanctions uniquement politique
monte à tout prix ce coup entre quelques
personnalités ce qui fondamentalement ne
changera strictement rien au
fonctionnement de l'état en russie en
revanche cela va continuer a détérioré
les intérêts de la russie et de l'union
européenne soulignant absolument les
paroles de la branche lors de la course
de la conférence de presse disant que
l'union européenne n'est pas un
partenaire fiable et sa spéciale europe
qui semblent eux-mêmes divisés sur la
conduite à tenir face au kremlin
pour quelle raison parce qu'à
l'intérieur de des pays membres de
l'union européenne
l'eau voit une fracture entre
certains groupes leaders on dira dans la
course 1 à la russophobie qui entraîne
le reste des pays de l'union européenne
il est fondamental de différencier d'une
part l'union européenne en tant que
structure et les pays membres de l'union
européenne puisque la russie développant
et continent a développé contre ou à
part de liant peine des relations
bilatérales avec certains paiements qui
eux sont intéressés à continuer des
relations bilatérales
dans ce cas on voit effectivement un
danger l'union européenne sans ce danger
puisque dans ce cas là c'est l'intérêt
de son existence qui est remise en cause
directement en fait tu parles d'une
politique d'état nation qui explique
bien des choses on imagine non le
dépendance au gaz russe était avant la
dépendance au gaz soviétique il n'ya
strictement jamais eu de problème en
tout cas la russie l'union soviétique
avant n'ont jamais utilisé il le gaz les
ressources pétrolières pour faire un
chantage politique au pays européens ils
le savent pertinemment
en revanche l'on voit la montée des
intérêts économiques des états unis et
du monde globalis atlantiste contre le
marché tenu par la russie et plus
influents par la russie évidemment sur
continent européen pour des raisons
géographiques absolument évidente
donc ici ce n'est pas un problème de gaz
russe est un problème de politique des
pays européens qui ne sont plus à même
de défendre leurs intérêts stratégiques
qui est celui d'une collaboration
normale et pacifié avec la russie ce qui
veut pas dire que tous les intérêts des
pays européens au corps de toujours avec
des intérêts de la russie en tout cas ce
qui est certain c'est qu'une politique
de confrontation n'est absolument pas du
tout dans l'intérêt des pays européens
en revanche elle est dans l'intérêt de
l'union européenne qui ne défend pas les
intérêts européens
alors la russie n'est pas la seule à
avoir subi des sanctions il ya la
birmanie le venezuela loi là
hong kong bélarus on rappelle un ce sont
les violations des droits fondamentaux
qui est en cause
pardonnez-moi la naïveté de la question
mais comment ça se passe pour voilà
décréter qu'un pays a violée oui ou non
les droits fondamentaux il ya une sorte
de mini pro ça au sein de la commission
européenne comment on décrète ainsi des
sanctions au sein des 27 exactement mis
le doigt sur un problème c'est qu'il n'y
a strictement aucun possédant le sens où
il n'y a strictement n'y aucune garantie
procédurale n'y aucune garantie
judiciaire
c'est une décision strictement politique
qui s'appuie sur une division du monde
extrêmement simple extrêmement primaire
il y a d'un côté les siens que l'on
condamne pas pour qu'il se passe il peut
se passer assange
il peut se passer dé répression violente
des manifestations en france ou en
allemagne
peu importe si aux états unis peu
importe il n'y aura strictement aucune
sanction
et puis il ya les autres il ya ceux qui
ne se plient pas complètement comme il
faut aux règles du jeu global aux
intérêts atlantis on voit le venezuela
qui n'a pas fait le bon choix puisqu'il
n'a pas fait le choix de boîte au bon
choix dans le sens évidemment le baliste
on voit exactement aussi le même
problème avec tiffany ce cas en
biélorussie qu elle même a déclaré
qu'ils ont perdu la rue donc ils ont
perdu le combat à l'intérieur du pays
on voit l'échec total du combat de
navalni en russie qui n'a pas réussi à
prendre la puissa par quelques
manifestations ponctuelles
il n'y a eu aucun soulèvement populaire
massif donc c'est une décision ce sont
des décisions strictement politiques qui
sont là en fait pour sanctionner ceux
qui ne se plie pas aux règles du jeu
c'est un peu si vous voulez la réaction
d'un mauvais roi qui va se fâcher contre
ces sujets parce que ces sujets sont
désobéissant et ne respecte pas sa
moyenne volonté nous sommes quand même
dans une vision des choses quelque peu
primaire
merci en tout cas karine bêcher golovkov
d'avoir été avec nous avoir apporté
votre point de vue